GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So today is a specific way
to solve linear differential
equations.
I'll take second order
equations as a good example.
This way is called
variation of parameters,
and it will lead us to a formula
for the answer, an integral.
So that's the big step, to get
from the differential equation
to y of t equal a
certain integral.
That integral will
involve the right hand
side, of course, the source.
And if we can do
the integration,
then we get a complete answer.
But in any case, we get a
nice form for the answer.
OK.
So what's the idea?
So we're looking for
a particular solution.
Today is about a
particular solution.
We have to know two null
solutions to get started.
So we must know these, y1
and y2, null solutions,
with f equals 0.
And of course we do
know two null solutions
when those coefficients
b and c are constants.
And we'll do it as a good
example, the most important
example.
But maybe sometimes we can
find the null solutions
when B and t are changing
in time, time varying,
and that's all to the good.
Those problems are
not easy to solve.
But it's really
constant coefficients
that we know it works.
OK.
What's the idea?
So the idea is to use y1
and y2, the null solutions.
If we multiply by constants,
we get another null solution
by linearity.
But the idea is to
multiply them by functions.
The varying, those
constants are not constant,
they are varying parameters.
So this would be the
form of the solution.
And we want to find a c1
and a c2 depending on t,
so that the differential
equation above it is solved.
So of course, I'm going to
plug that into the differential
equation and find out the
conditions on c1 and c2.
May I just jump to the result?
This will satisfy that equation.
We know that y1
and y2 satisfy it
with a 0 on the right-hand side.
So we just have to--
So it's c1 of t and c2
of t that are going
to deal with the f.
So here is the result
after putting it in there.
I discover that c1 prime,
the derivative of t,
comes into it times y1 plus
c2 prime times y2 equaling 0
will give me one equation
for c1 prime and c2 prime.
The other equation
for c1 prime times--
We'll multiply y1 prime
plus c2 prime y2 prime.
Of course, prime
means the derivative.
And that, when I'm plugging
all this into the equation,
I'm going to see an f of
t on the right-hand side.
I have two equations
at each time.
At each time instant I have
two ordinary linear equations.
They're straight lines
in the c1, c2 plane.
They intersect.
We know how to solve--
The most basic problem
of linear algebra, solve two
equations and two unknowns.
And we do that for each
t, and we get an answer.
So this leads us to c1 and
c2 and they depend on t.
Because-- Well,
actually it leads us
to c1 prime and c2
prime, the derivatives.
It just happens that when we
plug it in, the c1 and the c2
themselves disappear because
these were null solutions.
So we know that c1
constant would be good,
but when we put it in
there, we get equations that
involve c1 prime at each time.
So I'll take that away.
At each time.
All right.
Two equations, two
unknowns, we solved it.
OK.
And then when we solve them,
we put them back in to y of t
and can now just
write the answer.
I'll just write.
So I'm not doing all
the gory calculations.
I'm just going to
write the answer.
So y of t is going to be-- Just
to be sure, I'm looking here.
That's what I'm going to write,
and I'm going to part c1 and c2
into that-- c1 and c2 come
from these two equations.
OK.
So I have a y1 of t times c1.
Now, the c1 that comes out
of that happens to be-- Well,
c1 prime comes out of it,
so I have to integrate.
I have to integrate c1 prime.
So c1 prime that comes out of
that is a minus y2 times the f,
dt, and then there
is a denominator,
because if I have two
equations and two unknowns,
there's a little 2
by 2 determinant.
I'll just call it W.
It has a famous name in
differential equations.
And I'll tell you that name.
W of t is the determinant
of what I have there,
y1, y2, y1 prime, y2 prime.
Two equations, they
have to be independent.
They have to be
invertible to give me--
and it's this determinant
that is the critical thing.
So that's y1, y2 prime
minus y2, y1 prime.
That's the function.
Remember we know y1 and y2.
The whole deal is starting
with y1 and y2, null solutions,
and combining them.
And you see there is a first.
This is the c1 and now
I have to add in the c2.
It looks a little messy,
but it's just an integral.
It's just an integral.
So now what is y2
of t multiplied by?
Well, it's multiplied by c2,
and since this equation gives me
c2 prime, I'm going to have
to integrate to get c2.
And it turns out to
be y1 of t, f of t,
dt, divided by that
same determinant W of t.
This is-- Let me
tell you its name.
It's named after a
guy named Wronski,
so it's called the Wronskian.
You can call it that or not.
It's this.
So we know y1 and y2.
That means we've plugged those
in, we find the Wronskian.
We put that in these integrals.
We have the y2s and the
y1s and we're given the f
and we integrate.
Well, if we can integrate.
I don't plan to go
probably much beyond that.
Just I'll stop there.
That's a formula for the answer.
Well, I won't
completely stop there.
Let me do an example.
So let's see.
I guess my example will be a
constant coefficient equation.
So constant
coefficient when-- What
are the null solutions for a
constant coefficient equation?
You remember what happens
with constant coefficients.
You plug in.
You get s squared plus Bs
plus C times-- You're looking
for-- you're trying for an
exponential, and it'll work.
So I plugged-- This is
looking for null solutions,
because we have to
have those to start.
They are the y1 and
y2 in my formula.
So my variation and parameters,
the whole new thing,
is completed there.
Just if I want an example, I
have to solve the differential
equation, and for
that, believe me,
I'm going to make
B and C constant.
So I solve this equation.
So this gives me-- Of course,
I can cancel the e to the st,
because it's never 0.
So this has to be 0.
And that has two roots, and
the quadratic formula tells me
those two roots s1 and s2.
And then my null solutions
are y1 is e to s1t
and y2 is e to the s2t.
Now, I'm ready to go.
I'm going to put those
into this formula.
I have to do the Wronskian,
and I need another blackboard.
Sorry.
This is the only video so far
that went to a third board.
Can you remember I need
the Wronskian and then
I'll reproduce the-- So
there's-- Let me copy again.
Y1 is e to the s1t
y2 is e to the s2t.
And now that Wronskian is y1,
y2 prime minus y2, y1 prime.
And what does that
come out to be?
y1 is e to the s1t.
y2 prime is the derivative
of that, so it's an s2,
e to the s2t.
That's this term gave me that.
And now I subtract
y2, which is there.
y1 prime, which is the
derivative of this,
brings down an s1.
You see the beauty of
all these formulas.
Well, beautiful if you like,
formulas, not everybody does.
OK.
So now I know all
the terms, and I'm
prepared to write
again my formula for y
of t, my solution.
This is the climax now.
I'm going to use the
formula that came
from variation of parameters.
And I'm going to put in that
function, that function,
and that W, and I'm
going to see what I have.
OK.
So do you remember it
was y1 times an integral.
Oh, I had better use a
variable of integration here.
I don't want to put
t in there, because t
is the limit of integration.
So y1, do you remember, it
was a minus y2 e to s2--
I'll use just capital
T-- time divided by W.
Remember, there's an f
of t and there's a dT,
and I'm using a capital
T as the dummy variable.
And in the bottom goes W, which
is s2 minus s1 e to the s1T,
e to the s2T.
That was the first term.
This was the c1
that multiplied y1.
Now, I have to remember the
y2, the second null solution,
times its c2.
And that was the integral.
And again, now I have
a plus sign, I think,
so it was-- put in
parentheses there.
That was the W on the bottom.
So it was e to the s1T, f of
T, dT, dT, and that same W
down here, s2 minus s1,
e to s1T, e to the s2T.
OK.
That's the variation
of parameters formula
for these nice null solutions.
It doesn't get better than this.
And in fact, I guess I can
cancel e to the s2T there.
I can cancel the e
to the s1T there.
I can put this up
with a minus exponent.
Oh yeah, it's going to be good.
It's going to be good.
So here is a constant s2 minus
s1, the same for both terms.
Then I'll put this up here
as a negative exponent,
so there's an e to
the s1t, I'll get--
You might even see this coming.
I get this 1 over s2 minus s1,
and then I have the integral.
And here I have an f
of T in both integrals.
Let me just put
that f of T down.
And I have a dT.
And then what do I--
What else do I have?
I have this thing which I can
put inside but with a small t.
I'm not integrating that.
I think if you look there,
you have e to the s1t,
and then this will come
up with a minus sign.
Does that look good to
you for the first term?
And then the second
term will have
that same 1 over s2 minus s1.
Now, what do I have?
e to the s2T is going to
come up with a minus sign,
so I have an integral of
e to the s2, t minus T.
I think there's a minus.
Haha.
Don't forget that
minus, Professor Strang.
And f of T, dT.
Now, right there I'm
going to put the answer.
I'm going to put the
answer, and for me, this
was the highlight
of the whole thing.
I didn't know what would come
out of variation of parameters.
I wasn't-- I'm not at
all an expert in that.
But I just followed the
rules, put in these two
null solutions, computed
W, put it all in,
ended up with this
answer, and then I
was very happy to recognize
what this answer was.
This answer is the integral
of something times--
This is the integral from 0 to
t of something times f of T, dT.
And what is that something?
It comes from that term divided
by this with a minus sign,
and this term divided by
that with a minus sign,
and when you put
those in, what do you
get but the impulse response.
What I've called g of t.
And it's that t minus T.
So here you go.
This is the big moment.
g of t minus capital
T, f of T, dT.
Focus camera and attention
on that last result.
So that's the formula
that we end up
with from the
variation of parameters
applied to the constant
coefficient problem.
It's given us what
we already knew.
It's told us that the solution,
the particular solution, y of t
is the integral of the
inputs, the right-hand side,
the forcing term, f of T, times
the growth term, the impulse
response.
We could imagine
that at every time T,
we have an impulse
of size f of T.
And that impulse
grows by the impulse
response, g, over the remaining
time until it gets us to here.
Let me just clean that up.
And then we have to
take all those inputs,
so we integrate over all those
inputs, and we get that answer.
That's the ultimate
formula for the solution
to our differential
equations, to
our linear constant coefficient
differential equation.
So we've reproduced that
formula in the one case,
constant coefficient case, when
we can find the null solutions
and run this variation of
parameters formula right
through to the end,
and that's the end.
Thank you.